guten morgen philips-chef unseres
meinungs- ressorts es gibt ein thema
philipp das richtig heute morgen
besonders auf ganz genau und zwar ist
dass die weiterentwicklung dieses
islamismus skandals beim wdr worum
geht's wir haben auch gestern schon
darüber gesprochen und darüber berichtet
der wdr befördert eine moderatorin gibt
hier eine neue wissenschaftssendung
obwohl diese moderatoren in der
vergangenheit sich wirklich extrem
geäußert hat gegen israel über
islamismus sie hat den jihad verharmlost
sie war auf anti israel demonstration
der übelsten sorte und das ist gestern
alles hochgekommen das haben wir hier
bei bild enthüllt und jetzt sieht das so
aus die moderatoren distanziert sich in
statements davon sie bezeichnet zum
beispiel die teilnahme an einem alcotest
das ist eine der übelsten
antisemitischen veranstaltungen die es
gibt in deutschland als fehler und sagt
sie war da in einem umfeld und ist er
aber seit jahren nicht mehr unterwegs
gewesen gut das kann man bewerten wie
man milde wie man will ehrlich gesagt
ist ja noch viel viel mehr vorgefallen
wovon sie sich noch nicht eindeutig
distanziert hat aber das interessante
ist die reaktion des wdr und die gibt es
im prinzip nicht der wdr sagt wir sind
mit der autorin oder mit der moderatorin
im austausch und wir haben also ich habe
gestern den wd angefragt finden sie es
denn problematisch hier sehen wir mal
ein statement philipp und wdr hat
veröffentlichten e-mail hasan ist uns
als engagierte journalistin bei funk und
zdf aufgefallen aufgrund ihrer tätigkeit
es medizinjournalistin haben wir die
moderation von quarks angeboten das ist
das wissenschaftsmagazin sie hat den wdr
jetzt über ihre teilnahme an der al kuds
demo im jahr 2014 informiert so das
erste statement des wdr richtig ich lese
daraus aber nichts wieder werden dazu
steht wie hält es der wdr denn mit dem
al kuds moschee hält es denn der wdr mit
der verharmlosung von islamismus dazu
hätte ich gern statement das habe ich
dann wieder auch angefragt da kam nur
leider nichts zurück und das
interessante ist ja dass sie es geht
hier um ein wissenschaftsmagazin und
dieses wissenschaftsmagazin warnt
ansonsten in den artikeln davor dass man
unbemerkt von extrem ideologien
manipuliert wird aber weiss jahrelang
nichts davon was diese journalistin
öffentlich macht das ist ja nicht so
dass wieder großartig investigativ
recherchieren mussten wir mussten
einfach einmal ihren namen googeln wir
mussten auf ihren twitter-account gehen
wir haben ihren namen bei youtube
eingegeben und gab sich eine ganze lange
liste von tweets von auftritten von demo
teilnahmen von reden die sie gehalten
hat und das der wdr das einfach
jahrelang nicht weiß oder vielleicht
doch weiß und duldet und sich jetzt
nicht dazu äußern will das für nicht
skandalös wie drücken beim islamismus
einfach beide augen zu hier sehen wir
sie eben gerade links im bild beide
demonstrationen 2014 erwähnt heißt
findet ordnet uns diese demo noch mal
ein mit wem begibt man sich da ganz
konkret auf die straße wenn man dateien
können also der al kuds marshall kurz
ist die arabische bezeichnung für
jerusalem das ist ein marsch gegen
israel und ehrlich gesagt auch gegen
juden dagegen verschiedene islamistische
gruppierungen pro-iranische gruppierung
und diese demos deeskalieren immer da
weiß man ganz genau was einen erwartet
der wirt tod israel tod den juden
gerufen da wird auch sieg heil gerufen
der vita holocaust verharmlost also das
ist halt das schlimmste vom schlimmsten
sie war ehrlich gesagt aber auch auf
anderen demonstrationen unterwegs oft
sagen wir mal ganz normalen pro
palästinensischen demonstrationen die
aber ebenfalls sehr häufig ausarten auch
da wird ganz viel antisemitisches zeug
gebrüllt und sie sagt jetzt das war ihr
umfeld sie geht auch nicht mehr in die
radikalen moscheen in dem sie früher war
von diesem umfeld habe sie sich
distanziert ich weiß nicht ob das so
stimmt das wird man sehen sie ist
journalistin sie interviewt politiker
und will alles von ihnen wissen deswegen
könnte auch sie sich vielleicht einem
interview stellen und das ist nicht
alles mit einem instagram post abgetan
und es gibt zum beispiel ein spannendes
video erhält sie eine rede bei einer
palästina demonstration und diese rede
die hat es wirklich in sich das
interessante ist aber einer der
organisatoren dieser demonstration sie
sagte sie habe sich von ihrem umfeld
entfernt und getrennt einer dieser
organisatoren der demonstration der da
den ordner spielt und sagt wer wann
sprechen soll der ist jetzt auch beim
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk und zwar
bei funk das ist ein format von ard und
zdf und ich verstehe nicht warum man bei
rechtsgerichteten ideologien maximal
sind sie belässt er duldet man wirklich
überhaupt nicht zurecht und wenn zum
islamismus geht ja da weiß man nichts
weil sie ist wirklich nicht die einzige
die solche haltung hat beim öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk gegangen in diesem
sinne hat sich auch die cdu
landwirtschaftsministerin julia klöckner
in einem tweet geäußert das ist also
keine
entschuldigung sondern schlägt auch
politische wellen wir schon mal rein
während moderatorin polizisten lehrer
bei einer rechtsextremen demo gewesen
hätte das zu recht konsequenzen
inklusive linke forderungen
antisemitismus und islamismus werden
hingegen wie ein missverständnis
behandelt extremismus ist extremismus
keine rücksicht auf die absender ja
absolut was ich schon gesagt habe wir
schauen bei rechtsgerichteten ideologien
sehr genau in deutschland völlig zurecht
deutschland hat eine geschichte hat eine
verantwortung aus dieser geschichte
deswegen wenn es um irgendeine art des
rechtsextremismus geht ist man hoch
sensibel und man kann sich auch nicht
vorstellen dass eine öffentlich
rechtliche moderatorin erwischt wird wie
sie vor ein paar jahren bei einer
npd-demo gewesen wäre dass das passiert
ja nicht da ist der
öffentlich-rechtliche rundfunk stabil
genug um das natürlich auch zu erkennen
da und noch mal diese frau sie hat es ja
nicht umhin im untergrund betrieben
sondern sie war ganz offen auf
demonstrationen sie hat darüber
getwittert ich habe die tweets
gespeichert bevor sie sie dann über
nacht gelöscht hat es gibt unzählige
videos und dieses so genannte
wissenschaftsmagazin das ist wirklich
ganz viele artikel darüber schreibt wie
sehr man darauf achten muss dass man
nicht manipuliert wird von extrem
ideologien diese wissenschaftsmagazin
soll sie jetzt natürlich moderieren das
wusste über jahre hinweg gar nichts und
jetzt ich weiß nicht ich sind jetzt
zufrieden damit dass sie in einem
instagram post klargestellt hat leute
das war alles ein fehler ich hätte gerne
stellungnahme vom wdr wie sie inhaltlich
dazu stehen und was sie gedenken jetzt
zu tun ist einfach nur zu sagen mit dem
austausch mit ihr das reicht nicht
[Musik]